hi I'm song with McCarthy my question is
for professor be sorry des prez's
decided as I'm a student on the MSC and
I'm really looking forward to teaching
me later this year my question to you is
did you work in collaboration with the
other Nobel laureates that you ever have
discussions with them or did you just
work individually and somehow later your
work or blended in with the work of the
others thank you we work individually
the three of us up to about 19 18 fact
with night sorry 1990 when most of our
work was completed they were to us
working entirely independently from each
other but in 1990 dave morrison and i
came together and following that most of
our work in this particular theory of
labour markets it was collaborative but
i have never worked with Peter diamond
and I don't think they motifs and in
fact work with peanut almond